(somber music)
- I'm excited!
- I don't want to do this.
- I feel like I'm about
to get physically hurt.
(somber music)
- I'm hoping that my Latin
taste buds can take it.
- I don't think it's gonna be as bad
as people have told me before.
- Oh, you're full of
crap, it's gonna be bad.
- It smells good.
- Yeah, I like the smell.
- It smells great.
- It smells like dried prunes and farts.
- So how big of a bite?
- Wait...
- Oh my God, it got near me.
- Ready?
- One, two, three.
(banging)
- Child's play.
- Did I do it wrong or something?
It's not that bad.
- You don't feel that?
(laughing)
- Oh no, I'm scared.
- Oh no.
- Okay...
- Oh, I feel it now.
- Dude, this is so bad.
- It feels like hornets
are stinging my mouth.
- Chew it up.
- Ow!
- You have tissues, my nose
is about to start leaking.
- Oh my God, I'm sweating.
(screaming)
- Can I die?
- This is my second Carolina Reaper.
(screaming)
- [Voiceover] It's stuck in my teeth.
- It only gets worse,
like it radiates pain.
- It tastes good, it's just
like, it doesn't go away.
- It doesn't taste good.
- Are you crying? 'Cause I'm crying.
- I feel like I did a line of like glass.
- Would I ever have this again, maybe if I
was about to die, and just
wanted it to go faster.
- Someone just like (bleep) poking needles
in my (bleep) lip.
- We were happier earlier.
And now I'm on the verge of tears.
- I feel like if I sneeze
it's gonna be like a dragon,
like I'm fire-breathing.
- I am trying not to puke very hard.
- But the thing is like
I'm slowly prepared for it,
like I've had other stuff that just like
hit me at the wrong time.
- I wouldn't wish this on my worst enemy.
- I would, this would be a
good one for your worst enemy.
- I thought for a second I might die.
Like for a split second
I was like, it's over.
- [Voiceover] So what just happened?
- I just threw up a bunch,
this is the worst heartburn
I've ever had in my life, by far.